ron jesse
i'm renaming this competition papa don't
take no mess
because it's just the patriarchs of the
families going at it in our final round
of this competition where we're sending
you back to your home for just
to recreate this iconic weapon from
history
[Music]
the inigo montoya inspired rapier you
know the guy you killed my father
prepare to
forge all right good luck bladesmiths
we'll see you in
four days
i am almost positive that they're going
to do some kind of a flex test so i'm
choosing adc or v2
that should help with that the hilt is
one of the more complex pieces here
i'm actually going to use some really
old wrought iron one of the really nice
things about wrought iron is that it's
beautiful
my plan is to acid up so you can see the
lines around this thing
i'm working on my normalization this is
make or break
if it works well i'm all set i
grab hold of it with another pair of
tongs and go for it
i am very pleased right now to have at
the end of day one
a quench blade ready for temper
so far i'm on track after coming out of
the temper i noticed that there was just
a slight
little yaw in the edge i can take all
that out and grind it today
next i'm gonna move on to the hilt i'm
planning on forging all the parts for
the hilt
out of an old wagon wheel that my
grandfather used to own
so i'm flipping it over and i ended up
getting a crack
got a small crack that's developed in
the piece that i was forging for my
pommel i'm gonna try to see if i can get
that crack out of it
luckily took one more good hot weld and
heat and we're good to go
i feel better today than i did on day
one
end of day two i'm ready to go put my
feet up
my goal is to actually get done with the
blade today it leaves me two days to
work on all of the embellishments
i may get into doing some of the hilt
work today i want to see how it goes
with the grinding
if i over grind i could completely
destroy the blade
there's a reason that it took an eagle
montoya's father a year to make the
sword
there are so many pieces to this but for
jessica i'm gonna get this done in four
days
i've got a little bit behind where i
would like to be
i'm gonna try to make up a little time
i'm gonna go ahead and forge out my
knuckle bow
and hopefully by lunchtime we can start
fabricating the hill
this hilt's been pretty demanding
there's about six different pieces here
we spent a lot of time
trying to make sure everything was
dialed in
in the day three my health all came
together pretty nicely
just pulled it out of the edge
everything looks good tomorrow just be
fit and finish
last day i have to get done well
everything
now i can focus on getting that really
complex handle and hilt altogether
i'm forging out these bigger rings that
are on the side of the hand
that's eventually going to become this
really complex basket
uh perfect but for day four i'll take it
regardless of the outcome on this thing
i've had a blast making this
win loser draw it's just been so much
fun
good job thank you all right bladesmiths
my name is douglas marquez i will kill
the dummies
they are prepared to die to find out
what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i will take your
rapiers and deliver some thrusts and
slashes on this ballistics dummy
you're on your porch you ready for this
absolutely let's do it
all right ron let's talk about your
rapier here it is a little bit on the
heavier side but it's
wieldable and with a nice swish of a
slash
it cuts deeply overall sir your rapier
it will kill good job thank you all
right jesse it's your turn you ready sir
yes sir let's do this i'm extremely
nervous
i immediately start questioning my heat
treat and you know just a million things
go through your head
oh
all right jesse let's talk about your
blade here
it's about the same weight the thrusts
penetrate all the way
and to slash well deep cuts overall sir
your blade will kill thank you sir
that's what i came to hear
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test and yes i am going to
torture your blades
ron you're up first all right
you haven't guessed already it's a flex
test
i'm feeling a little nervous coming into
this test if i left any uneven spots
that could impact the flexibility of
that blade
good job man good job okay ron
that's a brutal test and he did really
well
if you look at your blade there's the
slightest
of bend in one direction barely
noticeable
the dimensions of the guard are spot-on
and uh it's definitely a strong blade
nicely done thank you very much
jesse you ready for this about as
nervous as a long-tailed cat in a room
full of rocking chairs but go ahead
foreign
[Music]
first things jesse the guards in the
proper scale
really nicely done issue is you picked
up a bit of a bend
still completely functional usable blade
well done
thank you
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
this is all about how sharp your blades
and what it does
to this dummy rondy up first you ready
for this yes sir
let's do this
all right ron talk about your edge here
this cut through
the clothing and right into the foam and
of course when thrusting it goes deep
overall sir it will cut thank you
all right jesse it's your turn sir you
ready yes sir let's do this
all right jesse i can still see the
little bend it took a tip
but the edges are razor sharp on the
thrust it goes deep
it will cut thank you sir
ron jesse you guys have turned in some
really quality blades
this is a difficult decision for us to
make and our forged and fire champion is
ron congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion
jesse please surrender your blade not
being the foraging fire champion
is kind of not what i was looking for
but i lost to a heck of a competitor and
a heck of a blade well done thank you
i'm very proud of the blade i turned in
but if i made this blade again i would
have took a little more time on my heat
treat made sure i had it perfect
being able to start this journey with my
son was pretty awesome
and i may not be the foraging fire
champion but i think i represented my
family well
ron congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion
you've led your family to this position
and you'll be taking home a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
brother from beginning to end this has
been a great experience
so the hardman house is getting the
forged in fire championship
you